[Music]
okay
good afternoon and welcome to catching
the r wave
how r and r studio are revolutionizing
statistics education at community
colleges
and beyond so a little bit about me
i've been teaching for 25 years
plus um at various hats that i've worn
throughout those years
i've taught k-12 i've taught
at a four-year college i've taught at
two-year college
i've taught computer science i've taught
mathematics
at all of the introductory undergraduate
levels
so it's a lot of teaching
i spent five years at great bay
community college in portsmouth new
hampshire
and while there i was the chair of the
math department in charge of the
engineering program
and i also created one of the nation's
first
certificates in practical data science
at a community college
also i'm married to harbormaster if you
know i'm on on twitter
so i have um created a github
that contains all of the materials that
are relevant to this talk
it's also a work in progress i'm
actually trying to put together some
materials that can
turn into a one cohesive thing
that a teacher can then just use as a
handbook
for any stats class in any textbook that
they might choose to use
so just a quick survey raise your hand
if you've either attended a community
college or have taught at a community
college
wow it's more than i was expecting
that's really cool
um it was about half the room so let's
do
just a real quick overview of like just
you know just kind of a history of why i
became
passionate about community college
education
all right like why is this such a big
deal
there are over a thousand community
colleges in the united states
that's a map of them
made in our
only 20 of them maybe more maybe a few
more
we keep adding a couple every year but
it's
under 20 that actually have a program
right now
whether it's a certificate or an
associate's degree or something
that's either called data science or
data analytics
compared to the over thousand we have a
little bit of a ways to go
uh you know as a comparison we did not
make this graph
in our this is a this was copied off of
a
um a report that was put out by the
government but
compared two-year to four-year colleges
we have about 36 percent
of all students who were undergraduates
in the year 2016.
36 percent were in two-year colleges
which is more than a third and it's kind
of
surprising to hear that number most
people
think that it's not quite that much
because we think about all the
undergraduate
colleges out there you're like well it
can't be but it is
and as far as um the numbers of students
who
receive bachelor's degrees
um i think this was yeah 2015-16
of all the bachelor's degrees awarded in
that year
49 of them those students had started
out at a community college
49 almost half
state state by state it does differ the
highest percentage is texas
where we are right now at 75 percent
so they're they're really pushing
community college education
the lowest is rhode island 24.
you can barely see it there but it's
there
so why did i become passionate about
this
because what happens is a student comes
out of high school
and and even adults who go back for
their
who might want to go back for a
credential
but especially high school students
let's focus on them for a second
they start out at a community college
and they get a list of programs that
they could
sign up for and
very few of them or not many of them are
really comfortable with math or science
you know those
you have few engineering people who just
are determined to do engineering you
know
that that's a kind of a unique crowd
but most students pick a program
and then they sort of stick with that
they're not going to diverge from that
hence the road and
what i would like to see is i would like
to see
more students exposed to data science
in the community college setting so that
then when they
transfer to a four-year college they're
sort of on a track to continue
that kind of work and maybe do research
driven
work and maybe maybe choose a stem major
sorry so i just wanted to show you the
program sheet
for the practical data science as it
exists right now at great bay
great bay community college is located
in portsmouth new hampshire
it's about an hour north of boston so i
was able to use the fact that it's
close enough to boston and
as a sort of justification for purdue
for creating the program
all of those courses are liberal arts
courses they
can transfer to any four-year college as
a liberal arts course i
deliberately got them uh
you know categorized as that
so along with this
work that i was doing to create the
certificate
i was also thinking you know how is it
how can we make it easier for students
to make the transition
from excel or from their texas
instruments
whatever whatever technology they're
used to how do we get them
comfortable with r
especially in that the first course that
i teach in the data science
curriculum is called elements of data
science
and typically it takes three weeks out
of a 15-week semester
just to get students up and running in r
believe it or not
yeah so i'm seeing a lot of nods well
so what if what if we started
introducing
r in some of our other coursework
like even in a biology class or in a
chemistry class
or physics class and in in my case since
i was
in charge of the math department i could
point to the statistics class and tell
all my statistics
uh instructors this is what we're going
to do
and this is how we're going to do it um
and
and i'm with you i'm supporting you i'm
going to teach you we're going to work
on this together
it's going to be we're going to stumble
a little bit
you know the first couple of times we
tried it it
was terrible and especially here
because in 2014 that's when we started
doing it
and the feedback we were getting from
students was
oh man you know you're asking me to
learn
programming and statistics at the same
time and i can't do it
it's too hard but
fast forward to 2018 2019
and now i'm like wow how can we get
r into the classroom how can we get it
into more classrooms it's really cool
it's really working
so you know very enthusiastic
and just a shout out for our studio
cloud here
our studio cloud has been invaluable
for the elements of data science class i
don't use it in the statistics class and
after the talk if you would like to know
why i can explain
but rstudio cloud is used in our
elements of data science
and most of the program outcomes for
that
um or i mean the course outcomes involve
wrangling data coming you know finding
finding the data sets that will answer a
question that you want to answer
and then um coming up with that tidy
data set at the end
okay and it takes a whole semester to do
that
okay like we'll just be honest
but before we before we talk about
how to incorporate r into the statistics
classroom let's talk a little bit about
why
so here's an example that actually this
was a slide
from a lecture that pearson publishing
produces
for instructors of just intro stats so
this is just a page
out of a lecture for intro stats
and you know yes you're going to learn
something if you if you answer this
question correctly
you've learned something but have you
learned what
we want you to learn i mean what have
you learned you've learned
how to use a formula how to how to
convert from an x to a z value
so i know how to use a formula and
you've learned how to use
the z table
that's it there's no kinds of
questioning here
that involves any kind of deep learning
or any kind of like
analysis why are we getting what we're
getting
you know just nothing like that
so the math department at great bay
community college
namely myself and i am just so you know
i've i'm a collaborative leader i was
not
just somebody who said we're gonna do
this we all met together i met with all
of my adjuncts
and i said okay
here's what we're faced with this is
this is what i'm thinking about
what do you think and just getting
everybody on board with it
is is a big big big deal
getting your stakeholders and your the
people that are
that you're going to be asking to do all
of the work
it's important to get them on board and
to get them enthusiastic about it
or you're not going to go very far
um but anyway you know we we decided to
make technology period a big part of the
curriculum
throughout the math department so you
know i one of the
one of my favorite courses to teach is
finite math
you do um input output analysis
you do you know there's there's these
things that you can actually do in
our in a finite math class it doesn't
even have to be statistics
so and and we were doing matrices in our
i mean
you know it makes sense
whenever a student comes up to me and
says oh it's too hard
i just point to this i'm like
and that's easy
tell me what about this is easy and and
what about it is
okay i've got this tiny little thing if
i happen to be
um site impaired
there's no way that i'm going to be able
to get to read anything off of that
tiny little screen on that casio if
you've never seen one of those casio
calculators
i should have put a picture up for you
whenever i um show
instructors when i when i am in a room
with a bunch of
community college instructors and i show
them this
and usually i'm going to be honest with
you i usually go to that
rdio dot it i don't know it's a snippets
thing
so i usually just go there
and i copy and paste this in boom
here comes the output and i'm like you
can do this
you can do this and and usually the
instructors are
wow can i do that on my phone
and and i say well yeah because you have
a browser on your phone if it's a
smartphone you have a browser
so you bring up the um the
a window that actually has that
executable code a window in it
just copy and paste and yeah of course
so they're amazed and and they they
begin to buy
into this idea
i and i'm also going to admit this is an
actual
image of a spreadsheet template that i
used
in my intro stats class
yeah apologies to anybody who had me
at that time because um
yeah so i mean you know it was designed
so that you could just put in the values
that you needed to and
out would come all of the value right so
you didn't have to use a table and um
i'm sorry but you know after that talk
this morning
you heard that you heard the keynote
right this is programming
okay i just want to put that out there
this is programming
all right
the same output in r with only a few
lines of code
basically is just and and you'll see
this in my github the the code for this
is in the github
it's just amazing to when i show the
contrast with
with educators about how how
much more useful you can
get or more use you can get with this
kind of output
and then so here i was
at that point you know when when we had
the cloud
and i was using just these little
snippets of code i was all excited and
now all of a sudden
shiny is here and now i'm i have to
admit i haven't played with shiny yet
but i'm getting the point across
from many people that i need to so
everyone's telling me yeah yeah you
really need to but
but it's actually going to be helping
in this whole effort to try to get
community college instructors
on the board with us because um
cal poly penn state and i'm sure there's
more
they have published shiny apps that are
specifically for the intro stats class
and you know i mean hey i'm going to
check them out
and then in addition to that
this is a stat prep is an effort that
began as a collaboration between the
mathematical association of america
and then this organization called amstat
which is american
sorry amatic which is american
mathematical association of two-year
colleges
amatic and then also
nsf is supporting the funding for this
and asa as well is involved
and what are they doing they are they
have these traveling workshops or the
workshops that are at various locations
around the country
anybody can can apply so there's
there's a i forget about oh it's not
working
there we are oops sorry i was trying to
use the pointer but apparently there's
no point
anyone can apply if you are an
undergraduate educator
you don't have to be full-time you can
be part-time
you can just apply and look to see if
there's a workshop that's
somewhat close to you but um
you know definitely you can actually get
a whole group of people to go like
that's what they want they want
they want like colleges to send like a
whole team of people of
educators and
i um i sort of put my own text over
there so you could read it
the next webinar is coming up it's this
friday january 25th
and it's about a multi-variable data
introducing students to multi-variable
data students who've never seen it
before
so you know it's really good effort that
um that katie is doing and you know if
you go under the about and the people
like it's all on my github as far as
who's involved and how you can uh get
involved to help as well
one of the shiny apps that the stat prep
team uses
is this is just an example for you
where they they use the shiny apps for
their training so they're actually
showing instructors what a function
is what parameters are
you know what are these things inside of
the parentheses and
like seriously if you've ever used excel
like there's
a natural connection between
what goes on with functions in excel and
what goes on with functions in
r it's not that difficult to make that
transition
also the american statistical
association
has provided materials as well there's
data
if you're looking for data go there
here's what we need we we need your help
community colleges need your help if
you've ever been in a community college
you know
we can make a difference and we can make
data literacy a reality in this country
in in our culture we want to make
smarter better educators
go out there to your local community
college make a relationship with
with the instructors there just start a
relationship start a conversation find
out what their needs are
a whole lot of educating going on we
want to we want to make
all these dots programs
with something relating to data science
or
some kind of intro and
if you're a developer make apps that are
available for any device
any device bottom line
is this the our experience we want
or this
thank you for having me um i want to
thank all of these people that
reached out to me and special thanks to
my husband who
seriously really helped me prepare this
talk there's my github link again
if you want to take a picture of it and
here's where you can find me so
thank you